[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
résistez résistez pour moi c'est c'est
le fruit de d'une réflexion qui s'impose
quand le triptyque républicain liberté
égalité fraternité est atteint par
l'injustice par les multiples atteintes
con qu'on connaît et qui provoque chez
moi un sentiment de révolte qui a été
bien bien largement expliqué par un par
mes prédécesseurs mais résister c'est
aussi tout de suite se confronter donc à
l'oppression l'identifier savoir comment
on va l'affronter et on se retrouve
aussi immédiatement face à la soumission
d'une partie des gens à l'oppression la
soumission c'est la manière dont on
obéit obéir c'est c'est finalement
accepté un lien avec une autorité
supérieure suffit de réfléchir
cinq minutes à la manière dont on
travaille de voir dans l'entreprise
comment on a une proportion aliéné notre
notre capacité à agir et penser
librement pour s'en rendre compte
avant de continuer le partage de mes
réflexions je voudrais simplement
rappeler quelques quelques phrases de
d'étienne de la boétie qui au milieu du
xvième siècle écrivait le discours de la
servitude volontaire et je vais je vais
les lire pour pas pour poly faire
offense
voilà je cite je voudrais simplement
comprendre comment il se peut que tant
d'hommes temps de boer d'antan de boer
tant de villes tant de nations supporter
quelquefois un tyran seul qui n'a
pouvoir de leur nuire qu'autant qu'il
vole bien landuré et qu'il ne pourrait
leur faire aucun mal s'il n'aime mieux
tout souffrir de lui que de le
contredire
ce maître n'apportant que deux yeux
demain un corps et rien de plus que naît
le dernier des habitants du nombre
infini de nos villes ce qu'il a de plus
ce sont les moyens que vous lui
fournissez pour vous détruire
d'où tire-t-il tous ces yeux qui vous
épie si ce n'est de vous comment est il
temps demain pour vous frapper
s'il ne vous les empreintes
a t'il pouvoir sur vous qui ne soit de
vous même quel mal pourrait-il vous
faire si vous n'étiez les receleurs du
larron qui vous pillent les complice du
meurtrier qui vous tuent et les traîtres
de vous même et 201 dignité que les
bêtes elles mêmes ne supporterait pas si
elle sentait vous pourriez vous délivrer
si vous essayez même pas de vous
délivrer seulement de le vouloir
quand on supporte comme ça ce type de
maltraitance quand on s'y soumet on
s'interroge quand même sûr je veux dire
on se dit finalement c'est pas c'est pas
simplement la peur de perdre un salaire
ou une situation où même la peur d'un
petit chef qui fait ça il ya aussi une
vraie part de conformisme social de
manière dont on se fond dans la masse
c'est tellement tellement facile dans
nos sociétés dans nos démocraties de se
fondre comme ça dans la masse de
s'abriter dans la horde et et de
finalement emporté en dehors de
l'entreprise
la soumission contractuels qu'on a pu
qu'on a pu y passer on l'emportent avec
nous et on diminue comme citoyen 7
cette soumission elle puise elle puisse
dans le conformisme
mais en même temps en même temps elle
est elle est dans le rapport qu'on a au
voisin je veux dire on est on est comme
ça
isolé enfermé et ça pose la question
finalement de comment comment on rompt
sa comme l'importance qu'il peut y avoir
à redevenir un homme à deux acquittés
l'animal a finalement ce s'affirmer
comme co m libre à reconquérir du
pouvoir sur sa vie sur son quotidien et
finalement être soi-même et le sam
être soi même ça me fait ça me fait
penser à ce que disait henry david
thoreau
l'écrivain américain qui écrivait milieu
du 19e siècle
c'est le père de la désobéissance civile
et qui disait si je ne suis pas moi
qu'il sera ça fait aussi réfléchir sur
la conception de la liberté dont on a
hérité avec la la déclaration des droits
de l'homme et du citoyen de 1789 qui en
substance dit que le la liberté d'autrui
s'arrête où commence celle du voisin
j'ai un peu de mal avec ça je trouve que
c'est une liberté de propriétaires qui
la définit comme un enclos où on
pourrait certes laissé libre cours à
tous à tous nos désirs ma condition ne
pas déborder mais mais finalement c'est
une conception extrêmement individuelle
et bon j'ai pas forcément cette
conception l'est de la liberté je pense
que la liberté c'est s'est jamais acquis
que c'est une lutte permanente entre
l'individuel et le collectif entre le
pouvoir et les contre-pouvoirs entre les
lobbys et l'intérêt privé s'est jamais
acquis et ça se voit tous les jours dans
l'économie ça se voit dans dans le
combat inachevé des femmes pour
l'égalité dans le travail ça se voit
dans les attaques terroristes
ça se voit dans l'état d'urgence et 60
millions de français mis sous contrôle
informatique s'est jamais acquis et
c'est pour ça c'est pour ça qu'il ya des
luttes des combats c'est pour ça qu'il
ya des parlements en démocratie pour un
discuter mais c'est aussi pour ça qu'il
ya quelquefois des gens dans la rue
résistez résistez c'est aussi quand on
s'engage comme ça dans la lutte s'est
lancé un signe lancé un signe à la
société en se disant on va voir si j'ai
raison si si finalement ça va pas faire
éclore des résistants qui s'ignore et
dès l'instant que ça s'enclenche comme
ça on part passe de dsk était là la
prise de conscience individuelle la
révolte devant dans ce que je disais une
atteinte à la liberté et à la justice
un petit groupe un mouvement collectif
je pense que la résistance elle se
légitimise dans le mouvement collectif
sinon avant c'est simplement une
résistance individuelle qui mérite
d'être saluée mais mais je veux dire que
elle rentre elle rentre dans l'histoire
avec avec le collectif
c'est aussi dans le collectif que qu'on
fait un peu famille con qu'on trouve des
gens qui pensent comme nous avec qui on
partage des idées avec qui on échafaude
des projets on développe des sentiments
d'appartenance
c'est aussi là qu'on prend sa part de
responsabilité de défense du bien commun
résister c'est quand même aussi se
mettre en danger
c'est jamais simple de quitter le
confort on va dire un peu tiède de la
soumission et dire non et on se retrouve
à assumer l'affrontement s'est s'est pas
toujours très simple c'est un un confort
intellectuel on peut se tromper on peut
carrément avoir tort et s'isoler
socialement c'est un vrai saut dans
l'inconnu en même temps en même temps on
découvre dans l'inconnu qui a souvent
bien plus de diversité bien plus
d'harmonie dans cette diversité que les
quelques parcelles de certitude qu'on
pouvait avoir avant donc finalement
résisté c'est assez joyeux on y est on y
retrouve du plaisir
on y retrouve le plaisir jeudi z d'euros
vont guérir du pouvoir sur sa vie et ce
plaisir cette liberté vous voyez elle se
fait dans le partage dans les changes en
multipliant les liens avec autrui ce
vraiment la liberté c'est plus de liens
et ça nous renvoie à ce que disait
bakounine qui disait de la liberté
d'autrui étant la mienne à l'infini ce
plus de liens aujourd'hui on a plus que
jamais besoin on se rend compte dans une
vie dans une société je dirai au moins
dans le monde occidental ou globalisé où
les les centres de pouvoir sont diluées
on le voit bien dans l'entreprise on
sait s'est jamais la faute de personne
c'est toujours c'est toujours très loin
de nous c'est 1 500 de direction qu'elle
est loin c'est les actionnaires c'est
ceci c'est cela on a même plus de patron
très rarement à qui on peut arracher la
chine
donc le cette dilution là ça donne un
sentiment d'impuissance sur la vie
quotidienne sentiment d'impuissance ça
fait du dégât c'est à dire que j'ai à
dire
la littérature est pleine de la maladie
des gens qui perdent leurs repères on
dit qui a besoin de sens que tout rien
ne va plus parce que les gens savent
plus où donner de la tête et savent tous
repérés à part de se vendre
on va dire électoralement à n'importe
qui donc le cette perte de repères avant
de se poser la question de la perte de
repères il faudrait se poser la question
de pourquoi les gens se perdent
eux-mêmes finalement et là on en revient
aux gens qui perdu dans la masse non
plus que que le miroir des autres qui
sont comme eux il n'y a pas forcément de
figure de résistance ou de miroir de la
publicité avec ses bêtises avec la pac
aux idées des héros de télévision bref
la perte de sens c'est surtout une
maladie de l'incohérence de la vie et ça
ça montre finalement que que l'être
humain n'est pas réductible à la place
de sujets dans la horde dans laquelle on
veut la signer et que il trouve son
équilibre dans la quête de
l'indépendance dans cette affirmation
est que cette indépendance n'est pas une
manifestation d'égoïsme
on s'entend bien aller dans l'altérité
c'est l'altérité qui nous donne
conscience d'exister comme êtres
singuliers finalement être libre c'est
questionner sans cesse la liberté et
avoir conscience que autant qu'un droit
la liberté c'est d'abord un effort moi
j'exerce ma liberté sans limite par
rapport aux autres
par contre par contre il ya une limite
indépassable elle m'est imposé par la
nature c'est elle qui donne finalement
le périmètre
le périmètre de vie c'est là où l'on
mesure la taille de l'être humain son
passage éphémère sur terre
son arrogance aussi quand il dépassait
les limites de la nature et qu'elle lui
rappelle et quand on intègre comme ça
c'est à dire au sens large la finitude
de la planète
ça nous donne la place dans le cosmos ça
nous fait prendre conscience de la part
de responsabilité qu'on a les uns à
l'égard des autres dans le
fonctionnement finalement des
écosystèmes mais aussi la nôtre pas de
responsabilité par rapport à la planète
et la planète
aujourd'hui elle vit une crise sans
précédent
qu'est ce que ça soit au niveau humain
vous ressources naturelles ça a été
évoqué ce soir je vais le faire
rapidement mais là on a tous en tête la
crise économique financière
démographiques sociales et puis epide
apprise de la biodiversité qui est
catastrophique versa ça atteint les
ressources dont on a besoin
les ressources en eau la crise
climatique qui est gigantesque qui est
devant nous et qui arrive très vite
bref est-ce qu'il faut encore parler de
crise parce qu'une crise
en bon français ça veut dire qu'on est
capable de trouver des solutions
les mettre en oeuvre et revenir à l'état
antérieur or à écouter les scientifiques
et on peut les croire et je dire les
scientifiques du giec six ou sept mille
scientifiques qui depuis 20 ans
s'échangent leurs travaux se valident
les uns les autres
quels que soient les pays d'où d'où ils
viennent donc on dépasse les
antagonismes nationaux
ces scientifiques nous disent n'y aura
pas de retour en arrière on a tellement
tellement dépassé tous les seuils d'un
d'écosystèmes tous les seuils de
biodiversité tous les seuils de gaz à
effet de serre dans l'atmosphère qu'il
n'y aura pas de retour en arrière
il faut bien se le médecin en tête et
c'est vraiment on a définitivement
changé nos la terre notre cadre de vie
c'est ce qu'ils appellent l'entrée dans
l'entrepôt dans l'ère de l'anthropocène
donc ya pas discours ayant on est sur le
champ de bataille de la guerre perdue
que nous avons mené à la nature
il va falloir en sortir il va falloir
trouver les chemins de paix savoir
comment on reconstruit en étant encore
en gardant pardon bien à l'esprit que
jamais on reviendra à l'état d'avant là
car bonification de la pause
r c'est pas forcément catastrophique on
est encore on a encore quelques dizaines
d'années 20 ans pour mettre en route
mais mais c'est un virage gigantesque
vous avez dû tous tous le lire ça
vers l'abandon du fossile c'est
gigantesque
le virage est immense et dans ce virage
immense est impérieusement rapide
il y aura des grands perdants et des
gagnants socialement économiquement tout
le monde n'a pas gagné on va se
retrouver face à des choses très
difficiles on risque des guerres il ya
déjà des guerres pour l'eau on pourrait
citer il ya eu le premier mort de l'eau
en france est mort as events faut se
rappeler que l'affrontement sur le
barrage de stevens c'est une histoire
d'eau sur le partage de l'eau donc c'est
pas si loin que nous on pourrait parler
de du conflit le riz décennale entre
israël et palestine c'est aussi une
question pour partie et papa et pas des
moindres de contrôle de l'eau de la
région
donc ça ça va se régler à priori dans
nos démocraties dans le débat public et
les politiques publiques qui devraient
qui devrait en sortir
par contre ça ouvre quand même parce
qu'un débat public ça suppose qu'on
conçoit très clarifiées sur les forces
en présence moi je pense que je n'ai pas
beaucoup entendu soir mais mais résiste
et ça suppose des forces en présence
ça suppose de la lutte du combat pas
forcément violent moi j'ai un vrai
partisan de la police en civil non
violente mais ça suppose d'avoir
identifié des dépositions et et de se
frotter l'un à l'autre et donc ce virage
ça ouvre le champ de nouvelles
résistances
là tout de suite immédiatement ça veut
dire qu'il faut tout de suite s'emparer
de ce qu'on peut pour arrêter de de
creuser des nouveaux champs de pétrole
d'arrêter de sortir des gaz de schiste
arrêter les pesticides et insecticides
très brièvement tout ça s'est fait avec
du pétrole ou du gaz naturel le faut
arrêter aussi la financiarisation de
tous et parce qu'on finit ans il arrive
aussi les brevets sur la vie qu'on est
en train de casser la dit qu'on est en
train de découper l'homme en morceaux en
pièces détachées pour nous prétendre
faire un homme augmenté bref toutes ces
atteintes
là ce que je définissait comme cas de la
liberté à savoir les limites naturelles
parce qu'on pourrait massivement dire
stopper le délire de la technoscience
sur nos vies qui est qui nous a menés
dans l'impasse actuelle où nous sommes
et qui prétendrait encore nous en sortir
il va falloir aussi résisté face à sète
à ce virage gigantesque à l'égoïsme des
pays nantis comme nous par rapport aux
pays les plus pauvres parce que
naturellement la tentation c'est de
savoir se souvient nous mêmes mais on se
sauvera pas nous mêmes sans sauver les
autres le voilà ça me fait penser je
l'avais pas prévu mais ça me fait penser
à une à une belle citation de de rené du
boss qui était était un écologue est qui
et qui disait on a besoin d'un en
substance on a besoin de sauver les
condors n'ont pas pour sauver les
condors mais on a besoin du chemin pour
y parvenir pour nous sauver nous mêmes
et je pense qu'on est dans cette
situation d'efforts et donc pour
conclure finalement à mes yeux résister
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment s'investir
oeuvré massivement complètement dans la
métamorphose écologique de la société
industrielle
voilà c'est créer multiplié les
initiatives alternatives y en a plein il
y en a une foule à tous les niveaux de
village de valets de ville
sap a encore changé d'échelle ça passe
pas au niveau de l'état donc il faut
libérer les énergies les imaginations
j'aime bien citer miguel benasayag qui
se trouve être un compagnon de réflexion
et qui dit
résister c'est créer mais il faut savoir
que c'est un vrai clin d'oeil à gilles
deleuze qui avait dit créer c'est
résister et après ces deux belles
paroles très très très modestement je
rajouterais que résister c'est dès
aujourd'hui faire demain je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]